last week I said Barack Obama gave me
disease but it was specially an allergy
to sulfasalazine my blood pressure
dropped to 80 over 40 and I had to be
rehydrated intravenously freaking sucked
[Music]
I've got a rash on my hands so it really
hurts to play guitar so yeah I've had a
bad week you want to hear about it good
if you don't want to hear about it you
should stop watching this video now
supervise me when I was sick well my
doctor told me that was probably because
of some kind of virus that had invaded
me and I believed my doctor even though
it was somewhat suspicious that this new
medication that I started taking might
have caused an allergic reaction well I
went off whew Wow and it hurt me again I
just hit myself the face with it faster
pills so the reason I switched to this
medication is because the alternative
which is this medication it's not cheap
of these guys they cost a dollar fifty
so when I drop one of these things on
the bathroom floor I eat it the big
problem though is that I am to take nine
a day these pills are much cheaper
they're like 15 cents apiece and I only
have to take six a day so basically what
happens is if you have health insurance
you get these pills which have no side
effects if you do not have health
insurance these pills which sometimes
kill you
luckily and they did not kill me however
because the urgent care doctor said that
is probably just a virus and not an
allergic reaction I went back on these
after I got back from Texas the next
morning I had a painful rash which I
still have and then that same afternoon
I had a really high fever a horrible
headache and my blood pressure dropped
so much that I couldn't stand up
I wasn't feeling any better the next day
so I went into the ER which is all I
could do and because I had really low
blood pressure and I was really
dehydrated the first-year med school
student who was being trained on how to
put in IVs had a really hard time but I
didn't want to make her feel bad so I
was just like oh no it doesn't hurt I'm
really good with pain so they got the IV
and they put two liters of saline in me
I felt significantly better and then
they put some steroids hydrocortisone
straight into the IV which helped bring
down the rash and decrease the swelling
in my lungs because also I was having a
hard time breathing and then they gave
me some more steroids by pill and then
they gave me a prescription for more
steroids now I'm not much for taking
steroids this the body God gave me
and I'm proud of it so I didn't really
know what the effects would be turns out
the effects are one I'm very hungry
and - I am very emotional because I was
feeling sick last night I went to calm
which is like cable TV on the computer
it was like I watched an episode of
Bones and I was like people died then I
watched an episode of house and then I
watched a commercial for Cisco the human
Network yeah so I've been doing with
that additionally they gave me lower tab
which is coincidentally the stuff that
dr. house is addicted to I've been being
careful with that they gave me this
because my entire body um
excluding two parts instead of six last
time last time I was my whole body
except for six parts this time it's my
whole body except for two parts you're
seeing one of them right now and the
other one is less mentionable um they
yeah they give me this ow
for example God because sometimes my my
skin hurts really bad I'm doing much
better now thanks to the kind doctors at
the emergency room but I really wish
that I had had to do that just because I
can't get health insurance anyways now
I'm back on the expensive stuff Oh
due to my infraction I've been reading
through punishment ideas you guys are
bastards how about some ideas that don't
involve death or torture because we're
being so strict about the four-minute
rule which I didn't really know we were
I've made two versions of this video one
is at youtube.com slash never F TBA this
video is a response to it so that you
can see the full like five minute
version otherwise I hope you enjoyed
this one John I will see you maybe
before the week is out